[Musique]
coco ça fait plaisir mais moi j'adore
les intros naturel alors aujourd'hui on
va regarder
turkish star wars a très vite savoir bon
alors c'est pas trés oui ça vous n'êtes
pas le choix
deux pilotes de l'espace s'écrase sur
une planète déserte ou un magicien
maléfique est à la recherche du pouvoir
ultime pour conquérir le monde
[Musique]
oui d'accord je vois le côté mais attend
des bleus va comprendre s efface ainsi
tous mes parents comme beaucoup faucon
millenium beaucoup à quoi faut combien
sommes nous à savoir thème pas trop star
wars bat est je vais adorer là n'oubliez
pas il ya plus de respect quoi on prend
les images de vraiment les mêmes faits
ressemble pas du tout à twin peaks un
vrai que chaque sous titre prend la
moitié
une phrase c'est huit lignes rapports
juridiques clairement assis tout le truc
c'est pas en espagne je vais faire la
gueule
l'omni star wars ni les turcs donc là
compliqué c'est la musique dynamique
[Musique]
là c'est bon là c'est plus tard mais là
on a du méchant de tortues ninja ça fait
plaisir
pointant les scènes d'avion dans
dunkerque s'est passé différemment
bahia turkish dunkerque 1 alors qu'ils
existent
[Musique]
et je suis perdu tél
[Applaudissements]
le chanteur du club d'auch la bernard
minet le fameux la fameuse coupe c'est
d'ailleurs vous retenez actuellement de
faire les crocs et les cépages et oui
comme c'est ma piste tu as
[__] si vous écoutez c'est assez
méprisant il est trop fort
[Musique]
il est passé à sale se fend d'une tonne
de cheval dans la nissan pixo regarderai
pas là c'est en train de changer
les bruits en ce feu derrière les gens
attendent et qui sifflent c'était le dit
c'est bon tu ne vois tu voi aux mollahs
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'il ya bien sûr la soirée
son sport
là c'était pour donnerait un danger de
mur c'est qu'il va encore faire des
cauchemars cette nuit c'est horrible
avec une musique doit bien heureusement
qu'on s'en est sorti ouais enfin hervé
il ya quand même 57 enfants qui sont
morts là il s'entraîne mais mes fils à
cet entraînement
[Musique]
[Rires]
sourire sourire [__] c'est sur moi ou
bien la justice tape dans le sable mais
katuku interroge commandement michaël
youn la course stub way jackman pour
descendre la graine banon en produisant
de la graine pas du tout à moi si
quelqu'un me fais ça tu as le mec il
s'est créé la tante quoi
[Musique]
meierhans chez vraiment personnages
préférés ya spin off à faire là bas mais
attention pas ta gauche il a trop la
classe 118 218 moi je trouve que le
héros est toujours très il est peu
transparente et émotion à chaque fois et
parce qu'il est trop classe est trop
fort
les
aulas au [__] ça c'était au 9e anna
match 6 à 0 l oréal et de brahms et le
meilleur moment du drame
[Musique]
il ne le touchera héros un seul ou
décisive ses propres
[Musique]
certains oui sauf un bruit de chasse
d'eau très bon tiers
les soirées fétiche et c'est des mecs
qui sont mieux comme ça on voit pas mais
une laisse relié à un gars comme un
sucre beaucoup fait ça ces implants
volés au zoo
bon c'est quoi ce qu au bout mais
attendez l'âme il était en train de se
battre là il est là mais c'était la vie
qui se bat elle ne comprend pas non plus
comme si on avait écrit le film alors
que gm tout quoi quand tu dis tout c'est
tout
tout ça parce que ça pourrait prendre du
temps ok ça suffisait de faire un feu
dans une poubelle en fait pour la
détruire
ça va du coup il va s'investir du
pouvoir de bp dont la bâche à eau
vous savez quoi c'est pas si mal à il a
fait les pieds en scred je pense il a
fait ça tout ça il est obligé
franchement la question se pose quand je
mets le pied ça fait ça c'est des effets
alors ça pour pour la petite histoire
c'est fait directement sur la pellicule
sa wii s'est gratté grade la pellicule
pour faire les majeures
c'était vraiment des trampolines la ceni
la laïcité six titres repris
ce week-end j'ai autre étoile de david
j'adore le foot ce gr
à obala ouais ouais aulas
[Musique]
la technique détrôner il a été fendu en
deux ça c'est pas mal
[Musique]
s'aventure que ça ira les relations
hétérosexuelles
voilà c'est très positif franchement
personne n'a dormi déjà nom n'a pas
dormi on n'arrête pas de parler des très
premier degré merci d'être venus
j'attends julien mais merci à toi la
prochaine fois j'invite la même équipe
on va film encore plus loin et plus
complet ça va ça va je n'hésite pas à
nous voler une autre heure et demie de
merde
merci d'avoir regardé ce deuxième
épisode 10 nous dans les commentaires si
tu veux voir plus de soirées nanars et
avec qui à beaune toi tout ça pue ça
s'allume
[Musique]
wir haben toi au cul les ta gueule
jamais ça l'enculé solo